So we looked at the formal
definition of what it means
for a sequence to converge, but
as a practical matter, how
can we tell whether a given
sequence converges or not?
There are two criteria that are
the most commonly used for
that purpose, and it's useful
to be aware of them.
The first one deals with the
case where we have a sequence
of numbers that keep increasing,
or at least, they
do not go down.
In that case, those numbers may
go up forever without any
bound, so if you look at any
particular value, there's
going to be a time at which
the sequence has
exceeded that value.
In that case, we say
that the sequence
converges to infinity.
But if this is not the case,
if it does not converge to
infinity, which means that
the entries of the
sequence are bounded--
they do not grow arbitrarily
large--
then, in that case, it is
guaranteed that the sequence
will converge to a
certain number.
This is not something that we
will attempt to prove, but it
is a useful fact to know.
Another way of establishing
convergence is to derive some
bound on the distance or our
sequence from the number that
we suspect to be the limit.
If that distance becomes smaller
and smaller, if we can
manage to bound that distance
by a certain number and that
number goes down to 0, then it
is guaranteed that since this
distance goes down to 0,
that the sequence, ai,
converges to a.
And there's a variation of this
argument, which is the
so-called sandwich argument,
and it goes as follows.
If we have a certain sequence
that converges to some number,
a, and we have another sequence
that converges to
that same number, a, and our
sequence is somewhere
in-between, then our sequence
must also converge to that
particular number, a.
So these are the usual ways of
quickly saying something about
the convergence of a given
sequence, and we will be often
using this type of argument in
this class, but without making
a big fuss about them, or
without even referring to
these facts in an
explicit manner.